okay 108
playing
uh ts oh i'm playing my uh
my long forgotten father
hikaru that's my goal this stream right
this would be takara
uh
kind of nervous now
yeah we played this line before
[Music]
good luck
thank you
he's in first place he's in first place
i'm just trying to break the top 100
oh my
bishop i got nervous i had a good
position too
h g3
oh no
stop hurting me
wait did i trick him i think i tricked
him am i winning
he has no moves
how am i winning this
this is
wait let's be careful
chuck
let's go
oh i feel so powerful
let's go goal accomplished
i don't know how i won that
i was getting smashed
oh
i'm sorry hikaru
wait where's the clip someone shared the
clip and then chat got busy
oh here's a clip
okay
i have to do some reaction
thank you eric you're very kind can you
please resign as well oh you're welcome
come on eric let's be let's be friends
here it's time to resign you're down to
peace
i'll still be your friend though
okay
oh come on eric
or did i just wonder oh
oh my god i just blundered
unreal
i
i just made a huge blunder
i made an epic fail
i made an epic fail oh my gosh
this is where i eventually miss meet
wow there's let's go here yeah i missed
queen c mate
he missed meeting one by the way did
quincy ate me he missed it oh and i just
found the queen oh shoot
oh that's so cool
thank you eric you're very kind now can
you please resign as well so polite
thank you and please
so when was the change of expression
come on eric it's time
or did i just blunder
oh my god i just wondered
unreal yeah that was like it was pure
luck because i think when i
when was it
because when that file opened
i didn't realize like there was
much hope
okay
oh